Nào tân hoa sã, ông Minh ông là được khu hội Myanmar bầu làm tổng thống tủ mì một của nước này sau khi rằng đã số phía ủng hộ,
của thế ông rằng được ít nhất hai trong chính bà chức tổng số 5 chăm tảm ủy tư phía,
một hướng tẩn kế theo quý địch. Ông sinh năm 1975, từ đầm hiện thị trí còn cứ lãn tất lực lượng vũ trang miệm mà trong hơn một thập kỳ,
từ năm 2011, đến khi từ trước bà của i thông bà nè mang nhìn không chăm xấu để tham gia chính cử.
Chông thời gian giữ tương vị lãnh đà của đổi, ông Minh ông là đông phải cho quan trẵn trong các quý sách của anh Ninh và chính chỉ của Myanmar,
kỳ tương năm 2011, ông lãn như bà trung tâm tru bụng máy điều hành đất nước,
giám xá tính chính chính chỉ và các cuộc bộ cử như thế ràn.
Theo dưới qua 3 việc ông chuyển từ vã trọng quân sự sang vị trí tổng thống,
khai hiện sự tí mối quyền lực dưới hình thức dân sự.
Các đàn thân của đổi trong đòo có linh Minh bành kế và phát triển đã sang ủy tầy trung của hộ Mỹ,
tầy đu tiền thẩn lợi cho chính tháng của ông.
Giờ qua rất trôi rằng việc ông Minh ông là đá trường thành tổng thống mới,
cho thấy sự tí mối phá cho lãnh đạo của cộng đổi trong mũ máy chính quyền Myanmar,
tập trung vào việc ord dịch tình chính chính chỉ và tuổi đẩy phát triển tình tế.